[音楽]
はいこんにちは
1今紹介されたあのプログラミング ruby を作った松本いうと思います
プログラミング運慶の人には難しいという風な言葉もありましたけれども
8そうですね実際にプログラミングしている人以外には
プロが右今興味を持っていない人にとってはプログラムがとても難しいものに見えると
いう風に聞いています
でえっと今日はですねまぁ
皆さんにプログラミングを体感していただいて実はそんなに難しいものじゃないんだよ
と
ですが入り口はそんなに難しいもんじゃないんだよということを紹介しようと思います
でやっぱりその遊びで覚えが一番いいと思うので皆さんにちょっと遊んでいたい
プログラミングで遊んでいただいて
でそれでプログラミングについて少し感じていただければ
いうふうに思いますで皆さん
コンピューターを持ちの方もいらっしゃいますけれどもここでプログラミングいきなり
コンピュータ開いてキー坊ただいてっていうのはちょっと難しいので
皆さんがコンピュータになってのなったつもりで
プログラミング私が皆さんをプログラミングしようと思います
じゃあちょっとみなすお手を拝借で得てを拾いていただいてちょっと1回手を叩い
いただけませんか
はい
何のことやらって感じですけれども手を叩くですね
ここからですねこの黒い欲しいマークを見たら手を叩くだと思ってください
はいとするとはいえーこのあまだいいですよ
で a
この黒いはずが2つ並んでますねじゃあこれを実行してみましょう
はい生の香港いいですね
でえっと黒い星を2回見ると2回手を叩くという意味ですねはい
でじゃあ次のルールを追加しましょう今度は数字を見たら数字の母
点数だけ次の動作を繰り返すというルールを入れます
すると a
3ほしいですねでは皆さんちょっとやってみてもらえませんか
せーの
あはらしいですねあの何の甲虫長もなく3階でございましたけれども
で a
こうやってですね段階的にルールを追加していきます
じゃあ z のマークを見たらアメリカの漫画とかだと z というのはそのいえ無理
な時のことらしいので
z を見たら1秒休んでください
えっちょっとだんだん美しくありますよはいじゃあこれですね
に星 z に欲しいですね
じゃあやってみましょうかせーの
[拍手]
あちょっとこれが来たけれど方のもう1回やってみましょうか
せーのっ
[拍手]
まあいいでしょえっ
はいじゃあここまで説明行ってきたもののルールを紹介しますね
まとめます黒い星を見ると体を叩きます
z を見ると1秒やすいます数字を見ると数字の回数だけ繰り返しますでこれはルール
ですね
deko
このルールを組み合わせたものがこうプログラミングになりますねっ
ルールに従って動くことが実行ですよねだから私がさっきの高ほしいとかを書いた時に
私は皆さんをプログラムしたわけですよ
で皆さんはそのプログラムに従って動いたわけですね正しく浮いて上でございました
どうもありがとうございますでは問題です
これを実行してみましょうちょっと難しいですね
山法師
z
山法師 z 7星ですねはいではいいですか
何やるか分かりますよね盾を用意してくださいねせーの
バッハ
ています
素晴らしいですね a 33-付与しですですねええ
さっきのプログラムはだから三三七拍子を実行するプログラムだったんですね
でじゃあ問題のに on
337拍子を2回繰り返すためにはどんなプログラムを書けばいいでしょうか
まあ
色々な方法ありますけれどもで
まあいろんな方法がありますけれどもどうしましょうね
どうしたりていますか
さっきこう黒い星は手を叩くというルールを導入しましたけれども
そうすると新しいルールを入れるといいかもしれませんね
国じゅうまるを見ると三三七拍子を実行しますというふうに定義してそして2回
三三七拍子を実行しますって言うと
これでさんそんな廟所2回実行できるはずですね
はいではちょっとやってみましょうかいいですか
せーの
[拍手]
ありがとうございました
はいえーじゃあもう一回ルールをまとめましょう
黒い星は手を叩くジェットは1秒休む
数字はその回数だけ繰り返すそして
=があると新しい定義を入れることができる先の33なるし見たいね
で a そういうルールでしたでこれをこのルールを使うとまぁ
3回手を叩くやるとか三三七拍子であるとかをプログラムすることができるわけですね
つまりそのルールを教えるとルールの通りに動くこれがプログラミングです
でコンピューターは1枚後も良くないので
でそうすると教えた通りに動くんですね
ルールの通りに動きますですからルールを決めてそれをコンピューターに渡してやると
コンピューターは
そのまま動くこれがプログラミングですね
そしてこのルールを組み合わせて仕事を記述することがプログラミングになります
ゲイ jr の踵部分ですね
でえさっきの声ですね山法師
z 3星 z 7ほしいですねこれはその
まあ皆さんが演じてくださった手を叩くコンピューターのプログラミングになります
さっきいったルールですねルールの方は今度は言語になります
ですからこれですねこれは手を叩くことを表現する
プログラミング言語になります非常に単純なのでルールがすごい少ないのであんまり
難しいことをかけませんけども
+もリズムを表現することができるルールになり
ですね
でこうやってその自分のやらせたいことをコンピュータのわかるルールで仕事を表現し
てコンピューターに教えてやるとそれがアプリケーションになります財源の
コンピュータはダダまあソフトウェアといってもいいですけれども
アプリケーションで動くわけですよ
で
えっとまぁ皆さん例えばスマートフォンを持ってらっしゃったらそのスマートフォンに
はアプリが入っていて
でそのアプリはを使っていろんなことができますよね
facebook にメッセージを書いたりとかですねあるいはこう
なんかゲームをしたりで友達にメッセージを送ったり様々なことができますけどもそれ
はそのアプリケーションを使ってこーう
いうわけですよそのアプリケーションの中にはその例えば友達にメッセージを切るため
にはどうしたらいいかっていうやり方が全部書いてあるわけですね
であのそれはコンピューターにわかるルードで書いてあるわけですよで例えばですね
えっとロールプレイングゲームをイメージしてください
ろーるぷ園ゲーム世界まあ皆さんの好きのロールプレイングは何ですかね
越冬でファンタジー系ロールプレイングだと思ってください粗相世界に入りました
ファンタジーの世界に入りスターモンスターが出てきたりえ
しますしあるいは仲間と一緒に冒険をしたりします
で a そしてその世界にで遊ぶことができるわけですねロールプレイング世界に入っ
て
でえええ
でその中にはですねメニューがあってでメニューを選ぶと戦うとか逃げるとか
魔法を使うとかそういうことができるようになるわけですね
で a そのコンピューターの世界の中に入ってコンペの中でそういう行動するための
選択肢が提供されるわけですね
所ですね8そのゲームを誰かの作ったゲームに
の世界に遊びに行っているそのゲーム遊んで打ったときにはその選択肢は
はそのプログラマーの人があるいはそのゲームをデザイナーの人が決めた選択肢を選ん
でいるわけですね
魔法使うと何が起きるかとのは自分で決めたわけではない
んですねっ
でも考えてみるとそのう
デザイナーの人が世界を作ったんだったらその世界を作ることそのものコンピューター
を使って世界を作ることっていうのは不可能ではないということですよね
で
ど自分で自分の世界を作ることも
まあ簡単かどうかは別としてやればできるんですね
でそうすると自分で世界を作って遊ぶことができるわけです
でそれがそのプログラミングの一番の醍醐味ではないかなというふうに思います
私は子供時代にコンピューターを使ってプログラミングを始めた時に
で結局何がしたかったかというと自分で
自分のルールを自分の遊ぶルールを決めたかったんですね
でどうぞ
コンピューターのプログラムのでゲームをしたりとかするとまぁ私にとって難しすぎ
たり
私にとって面白くなかったりするときに例えばそこを改造してあるいは自分の木好きな
ルールで遊びたいわけですね
で結局の自分の好きな世界をつくって自分の好きなルールの世界を作りたかと
でゲームをプレイしているとだからゲームのルールを変えたかっ
下そして自分だけのゲーム自分とって素晴らしいゲームを作りたかったんですね
それが私がエアのプログラミングを始める最初のきっかけです
あっ
しかしですねえっと
構想するつしているうちにそのプログラミングっていうのは
ただゲームとを作るっていうとだけなくてコンピュータお店操る感じになってるわけ
ですね
それすごくとでも楽しくてで考えてみるんですね
ゲームっていうのは一つのアプリケーション1スペアナわけですよねでそのゲームの
ルールを
ゲームを開発食ったり改造したりする
とゲームのルールを自分で決めて自分で変更することができるんですね
でその過程はプログラミングですねでプログラミングシェルと
ようプログラミングにもルールがあるんですよそれは
交差切った言語なんですね
でコンピュータと人間の間にどういうふうにプログラミングを表現するかという
取り決めルールがあって
でそれがプログラミング言語になります
で私がコンピューターでプログラミングを始めるようになってまだ若い頃にその
プログラミングそのものゲームを作ったりゲームを改造したりして遊んでいるうちに
そのゲームの表現である
ルールの表現であるプログラミング言語に関心を持つようになりました
でそのうちですねそのゲームが自分の好きなルールに改造できるんだったら
言語も自分の好きな
言語作りたいなというふうに思いましたそれまだ高校生だったんですけども
でプログラマーがプログラミングする時にどんな風に考えてどんな風に世界を捉えて
どんな風に表現するかということを
その自分で決めたかったんですねこういうふうに表現したいとか言うことを決めた
でそう思ったのはここ
個性的だったんですけども私が高校生の時にはまだインターネットもないし
でえっと大学まあまだ大学で勉強もしなかったのでスキルもなくて知識もなくて
で言語を作ろうと手元でもできなかったんですねだけどその夢だけは持っていて
で a その後高校卒業して大学に入って
勉強して就職してで a さまざまなスキルを身につけて
そして大体そのプロミン言語を作りたいなぁという夢を持ってから10年くらい経って
初めて自分の言語を作ることができました
それルビー言う名前ですけれどもでそうするとその b には文法とルールが
あってルビーのプログラミングの書き方があるんですね
でそうするとその書き方の背景には ruby の考え方であるとか
それからまあ大げさな言い方をするとルビーの文化というものがありました
でそれっていうのは私がルビーに込めた
こう設計思想とかですねそういうものを反映した
文化を ruby を使ってる人たちみんなが共有するようになったんですね
それは多いすごい大雑把な言い方をすると
ruby を使ってる人たちでて作っているその一つの世界という意
言い方もできると思います
でそれはだから私が指を作ったことによって今まで存在しなかった新しい世界ができた
というんですねはい
で a コンピューターという単語はもともと計算する機会という意味ではあるんです
けども
もう今やもう計算機ではなくなったんですねでへ
コンピュータは今は世界シミュレーターになっているんですつまりコンピュータの中に
何かの世界をつくってそれを私たちに見せてくれる機会になっています
そのまあファンタジーロールプレイングゲームの世界が一番分かりやすいですよね
です足をその世界はコンピューターの中できていますで a だけどそういう意志と目
で見てわかるの世界だけじゃなくて
プログラミング言語の世界であるとかアプリケーションの世界であるとかゲームの世界
であるとか
ます様々な世界を作ることができてそしてそれを私たちに見せてくれるための機会とし
てコンピューターは存在しています
ということはその機械の中に世界を作るプロセスであるプログラミングは実はその世界
を創造するプロセスなんですね
でですから8まぁ最初は単なる
好ゲームでしたでその下には言語があって
で号そのさに os があってて薄くするように階層的な世界になってるんですけども
それぞれの世界ですねこう私たちはいろんなものを自分の想像力の限り
つ分を作り出すことができるんですねといえばプログラミングは想像するというよう
ですね
で私の中に持っている妄想
を魔法が使える世界とかこう
モンスターいる世界とかですね現実にすることができる
こうツールなんですねそれは世界の創造でありとても楽しいことだと思います
でその楽しさを通じて世界を作ることができること
そして現実世界に駅を与える
ことそれがプログラミングのパワーだと思います
はいところでですね
さっきの問題にのプログラムなんですけれども実は間違いがあります
でその間違いを見つけられるかどうかはみなさん宿題にしておきますどうもありがとう
ございました
[拍手]